é muito bom dia a todos
eu vou falar da habitação partilhar uma
paixão minha da habitação habitação em
angola e como é que a propósito da
habitação em angola ao longo do tempo e
do espaço
tanto nas áreas rurais como nas zonas
das áreas urbanas
então vou mostrar o percurso que vamos
fazer deste 15 minutos é vamos falar da
combata mais rudimentar do do sul de
angola por nena algumas com batatas do
centro centro leste
o chico lunda norte na segunda sul até
chegarmos ao modelo suburbana né é um
modelo suburbano aí já vamos falar das
periferias rangel cazenga
nos conhecemos e o com alguma da do
êxodo rural pra vida confirma a má
armado foi criando várias vários densos
de um sexo estão em bairros informais
bairros sem infraestrutura sem
saneamento caóticos quer dizer a
organização que tinha no campo da
família alargada foi forçada a
desagregar-se e aqui pra minha
capacidade e criando pequenos grupos e
ainda vamos ver depois que a génese ea e
e amor o módulo da família alargada
também se foi levado também pro pro
urbano
então temos também mostrar alguns
exemplos de programas de habitação pelo
pelo pelo executivo é do ministério do
urbanismo e habitação e também
questionar para onde vamos temos uma
herança vernacular temos a aprender com
os meus sets e pra hebron do caminho daí
o ponto de interrogação para onde vamos
é hoje em dia fala da sustentabilidade é
é moda sustentabilidade é sustentável
mas a sustentabilidade já vinha há 200
anos há 300 anos está uma cubata o valor
no neném
são várias como batatas em círculo
numa atualização em círculo e que o
chefe da tribo está no centro as com as
suas esposas de seus filhos sobrinhos
uma família alargada dentro de um
círculo ea sustentabilidade vem na no
encontro dos materiais locais desde a
madeira desde o arrefecimento dessas com
batatas é esterco de gado esterco seco
30 é tudo é aproveitado no sítio
mostramos para o colégio o chico cubatão
burla usando novo materiais locais do
como a madeira quer dizer à habitação
tanto formal como a características
construtivas variam em função de
materiais locais em função do clima
ciúme de um centro legal seco se é seco
uma zona a zonas do sul onde variam em
função das características climáticas
a idéia é aprender com os materiais
locais e aprender com as parcialidades
como é que as pessoas vivem no campo
normalmente dentro do que num ser no
centro do quilombo
a cozinha está centralizada a 0 por
exemplo estamos a ver aqui com o coração
do domingo da farinha de milho
neder da seleção do milho ou pisar
domínio do pilão que depois de uma
furada sair uma samba
estamos no rural ao êxodo rural para a
cidade ea uma ruptura tanto dos árbitros
como david modelos da habitação
é sabido que aproximadamente 80%
luanda é é um dos bairros informais 20%
é urbano consolidado
obviamente com os vários programas da
coligação é quanto tempo a mudar este
cenário
são bairros muito densas podem ver podem
vê-la o fundo o caixa consolidado de
edifícios e os musseques denso apertado
parece caótico mas vamos analisar bem
tem
alguns dos comuns podemos identificar
alguns modelos espaciais muito
característicos como por exemplo o padre
o pátio que já vinha da herança hispana
khullar do kindle sem circular desde aí
como é muito apertado nos quatros ainda
existem
são elas que vão mudar esses pátios ea
partir desses partidos é que são feitos
acessos à habitação e também são nesses
pattinson da ua convivência entre as
família família alargada como podemos
ver aqui
aí o pátio que pato estudar para 56
é é habitações e à família alargada
mais uma vez o patriarca com sua mulher
com seus sobrinhos e filhos também os
passos trio no século os humildes gostam
de jogar à bola quer dizer é uma febre
do que querem ser criança cristiano
ronaldo está nas ruas da segunda mão
dadas aos pátios e também é as
atividades do dia-a-dia socioeconômicas
informais do auto emprego desde as
janelas abertas desde há cabeleireiros
desde os mecânicos desde a venda
informal o comércio informal
agora este gráfico foi para um cadinho
tempo a explicar um bocado é mostrar as
várias tipologias de habitação na zona
urbana
nós temos uma sociedade tratorizando
socioeconomicamente tossia muito
desequilibrada
temos uma minoria muito afastada com
algumas posses e uma esmagadora maioria
como podemos ver a vermelho a a baixa
renda
depois temos 11 o percentual já que o
investimento média renda
e onde é que elas vivem temos
categorizar possível clássico do desde
os os desde os industriais os
empresários desde o os patriarcados
desde jovens licenciados que trabalham
nas petrolíferas desde o funcionário
público um chefe do departamento das 17
único médio do público até chegar o qual
o
um trabalho um trabalhador informal o
duo tem um auto emprego e que é
justamente neste 30% dessa desta desta
dessa classe social que nos merece ter
mais atenção no que toca à habitação
onde eles vivem classe mais abastada no
centro da cidade não tava tona o podemos
ver o bebê são também no talatona e
nunca de mais a mais atrás mira amaral
falado até chegar o eca é a última que
são joão são hoje um sexo só os grandes
no sexo algo usando por exemplo alguns
gramas de realojamento está mais ou
menos dessa classe social não é só para
situar no território onde essas classes
sociais
como podem ver aí olha que vivem e como
é que é e como vive nem o sol são alguns
exemplos
quando fala do talatona também o outro
condômino talatona nova vida já marcadas
e viana objeto das 500 casas de viana e
isso sim é o zago e 17
isso é justamente esta esta categoria
que merece uma atenção especial temos
claramente uma dicotomia temos rural
temos uma cultura é brusca devido ao
conflito armado para urbano urbano temos
urbano formal e urbano informal e não
formal vamos vendo algumas soluções
movimento questionáveis soluções de
habitação seja é o sangue seja o nova
vida seja ou seja que lá funcionava no
sentido de como é que essas habitações
se enquadram em termos de clima em
termos da educação sociológica como as
suas 60 e viver este bairro é importante
também fazer essa reflexão mais uma vez
tentando filosofar um pouco é temos uma
herança africana
não digo angolana e africana banco do
centro no nós nós temos um jango
normalmente é um espaço circular
normalmente situado nas zonas rurais no
centro do quilombo
e é justamente aí no jango da
crescia da partilha do conhecimento do
debate e no momento o centro onde está o
chefe da ajuda da família o patriarca
que em em oposição não vai poder lança
ocidental retilínea do carlos e do
pulmão anos e como tal está a falar de
mestiçagem e obviamente quando se fala
do urbanismo tendencialmente e é mais
econômico a a linha reta e uma
tonalidade da economia há necessidade
também de mixagens nunca toca abordagem
uma abordagem urbanística nova titular é
quando começa a partir do software que
me encanta são os os fractais
refratários no fundo é é o crescimento
seja de um sistema fechado de um do
grupo da habitação já deu uma de um
aldeamento uma razão crescimento com
base no módulo numa forma refratária nos
acompanham desde a ficar banda desde o
senegal à áfrica do sul
o fatal nada mais é do que como podem
ver na figura do canto superior a um
canto inferior direito
é uma grande aldeia são círculos dos
círculos de círculos isto é no centro
desta desta desta aldeia de circo está a
família principal onde está o
ao soba o chefe o patriarca com a sua
esposa seus filhos e depois fora desta
neo também circular tem várias vários
outros círculos que são as outras
famílias próximas que zé é um círculo do
círculo dos círculos tanto tempo também
podemos ter estuprado dança haver hamas
em gaza a umbigada sendo umbigo o centro
da do homem eo a umbigada é dar sabem
fiocruz
várias pessoas em círculo e duas pessoas
vêem o centro do circo e no centro do
homem são só fazer umbigada quer dizer
mais uma vez frágil na dança como a
capoeira também é a poeira movimentos
circulares das áreas em círculo
mas o centro de gravidade é sempre é o
umbigo natal foi com os cravos pra
américa e tem é que muitos muitos
amantes do pop há uma data fechada desde
que o prêmio também é dançado em filhos
mas o envolvimento todos ainda do centro
do umbigo de energia que vêm de dentro é
muito interessante como é que conseguem
daquela forma mas eh eh eh eh um
tratávamos a companhia justamente aí
podemos lugar comum
pesquisas futuras com o próximo e dex
falar sobre os fractais então é procurar
nos perguntar para onde vamos
por aqui que nos quer que tipos chegar a
ser a cubata as pirâmides será o piloto
do corpo use em movimento moderno para
onde vamos pra nosso nós a nova
habitação qual é o qual terá os
possíveis caminhos a dar algumas
sugestões e criar um ou quebó polis que
é uma união logistas com a junção de
duas palavras kimbo
dodô assentamento macular rural e poles
que cidade
a junção desses dois conceitos surgem no
futebol por isso o pinball pio xii é uma
cidade diz criar um novo organismo
principalmente nas zonas periféricas das
grandes centros urbanos principalmente
próximo dos grandes corredores verdes
próximos grandes intuições verde onde
podem podem se criar a atividades
agrícolas
estamos a falar por exemplo afunda
calombo execução cidades intermédias
entre o campo ea cidade para que é a
funcionar como tampão que as pessoas não
viam diretamente pra para a cidade e
ficavam ali nessa transição que é uma
zona urbana mas com uma componente rural
muito forte onde é porque podem ver aqui
um modelo urbano do que em bairros da
direita são as as casas muito econômicas
fazem uns cria um no centro um grande
pátio de fundo a criação do quilombo
aqui podemos ver uma imagem cada casa
teria uma horta para elton autoconsumo e
também as duas teriam grandes grande que
taxa as lavras maiores mas cada casa
teria sou o seu espaço de cultivo e ao
centro teria tal espaço de convivência
com convivência de todos
a possibilidade se for uma família
alargada pode ser preenchido os muros
pode ser vamos ter um pátio e aí vemos
novos tratados o pátio depois outro
pacote maior e isso pois vai explicando
por último com a mesma métrica
está é a planta e um sistema um modelo
executivo são moradias evolutivas que
com o tempo podem adicionar mais um
quarto pode ampliar a cozinha pode criar
um espaço comercial à frente
passamos então para uma outra solução
mas mais para zonas subprefeituras
suburbanas
no caso concreto do cazenga que é um um
sexo muito denso mas é a célula urbana
por causa do caso ainda funcionava como
uma intervenção uma parceria
público-privada privado tem que entrar
assim o estado fazia as principais
infra-estruturas o o o privado para
entrar analisado os lotes ou a o terreno
os mais valiosos principais nas ruas
principais
mas em companhia do quanto a partida
eles teriam que fazer construir
habitação social
mais uma vez essa vida social eu seria
da reinterpretação do musseque mais uma
vez os pátios e os fractais 17 ontem
vários padres
então esta solução habitacional não
podem ver aí que são só edifício de
cinco pisos régio piso térreo comercial
e mais quatro pisos da habitação mas
todos em torno de um pátio é importante
neste processo de requalificação a
criação de emprego local e as parcerias
público privadas a o estado é é uma
monitora até a parceria privada vem traz
a tecnologia da reciclagem do entulho e
tudo isso mas que não vai demolir várias
casas
a estrutura é é reaproveitado ou
reciclado para produção de materiais
posição e pode perfeitamente ser
permitir a autoconstrução dirigida que
as pessoas são ensinadas são formadas há
como aplicar esses materiais e as
tecnologias muito muito muito pequena é
é para habitação social de baixo do
baixo custo muito baixo e evolutivo é
oposição dirigida evolutiva das famílias
recebem um apartamento apenas só com o
módulo sanitário o quarto de banho e
cozinha
o interior com com ajuste com
autoconstrução dirigida
eles vão completando o interior